Jorge Hirsch who was the creator of
something known as the H index which is
really the precursor in some sense
although I think Jorge you correct me if
I'm wrong I think Jorge came up with it
after Google when you have this
extraordinary Theory that's gotten
tremendous amount of attention and with
the attention comes criticism so what do
you put to this stock of like how do you
weight the H index versus the tedx index
I think it's really good at what it's
for which is measuring the success in
the community of uh contributions in the
literature and for the purpose of
academic hiring like do you want to hire
this person well their H index is a good
measure of how well received their
contributions are within the community